few weeks ago I made the I thought
uncontroversial observation that condoms
are kind of gay the conclusion that one
draws is that condoms are kind of gay
the hosts of The Young Turks apparently
took issue with my clear as day
observation no you
freaking I am going to examine their
reputation of my point and producer Ben
Davies has issued me a challenge which
is to try not to laugh at Chen yuger for
as long as possible so without further
Ado take it away condoms are kind of gay
that's the expert commentary uh that you
can hear by Michael nolles I I I don't
know how to respond to that maybe we
need to hear more but first some more
context so in order to understand what
could have possibly led to him making
that statement we'll have to watch him
whine about Fringe culture War nonsense
so stay tuned for that it's terrible for
me to whine about Fringe culture War
nonsense but it's very very important
for them to whine about me whining about
the supposedly Fringe culture War
nonsense something doesn't add up here
keep going I think a lot of people are
beginning to notice the contraceptive
mentality is the beginning of the pride
mentality that's a great point because
the contraceptive mentality divorces sex
from the consequences of sex which is
exactly what gave us the pride moov
there there's no distinction here people
are beginning to realize okay if I don't
like this insane anarchistic view of sex
that is totally self-centered and
divorced from any ends well then maybe I
got to rewind it and ask what is the
point of sex I mean I can just quickly
answer uh one of the main questions he
had there about like why you know why
engage in this narcissistic act if
you're not trying to procreate
pleasure pleasure I'm not a religious
person
however if I were a religious person I
would thank the Lord okay for giving us
the physical capability I know not all
of us and thoughts and prayers for those
folks but but generally speaking the
physical capability to experience sexual
pleasure sex is pleasurable yes that's
one of the main things that draws us to
it and that's good I'm not denying any
of that that's obviously a point of it
just like pleasure is a point of eating
a big
[Music]
hamburger it's not the point of eating
the hamburger though it's an ancillary
feature it's rather nice I'm glad it's
one of the allurements of eating a
hamburger but the point of eating the
hamburger is to nourish me and to
sustain me so that I can go about my
life and pursue my other higher purposes
if I divorced the the purpose of the
hamburger from the pleasure what would I
do well I'd probably stuff my face with
a lot of different hamburgers and then
I'd I don't know I'd probably go vomit
up those hamburgers because I don't
really want the calories you know I just
want the the pleasure of the taste as
our culture has divorced the pleasure of
sex from the end of sex which is
procreation we've got a declining birth
rate so a dying population we've got
people putting off marriage we've got
people getting divorced at much higher
rates we've got a lot of social
breakdown It's Made Men kind of weak and
S it's made us all very selfish it's not
very good that's not to say sex is bad
but it's to say that divorcing things
from their purpose does not end well so
look there's two core issues here that's
a massive difference between the right
wi and the left wing and this clarifies
things and why I think no rational
person could be a right-winger um so
there I said it catch feelings so uh
number one I guess I lost I that caught
me by surprise cuz I said okay I'm not
going to laugh but then what made me
laugh was not some bombastic comment
from Chen it was the suggestion that his
statement Were Somehow bold you know he
said I don't think a rational person
could ever be conservative there I said
it that's right most people don't have
the courage to say such an uncommon
expression as that ah but I said it and
that's what got me okay didn't last very
long keep going he is saying the only
sex that should be allowed presumably is
purpose the purpose of procreating and
creating children to which put a pause
there you see this is where he slips in
the little trick cuz he says well
presumably what he's saying is that
every other kind of sex shouldn't be
allowed my only point was that the
sterile sexual ethic is not not good
what if I want to have sex before I get
married I guess you just have to be
prepared to die the sexual Revolution
broadly is responsible for that you
really think this is what sex is for you
really think this is good have the
consequences of this really been good
nobody would would answer yes is such an
absurd point no one in America believes
that only these radical lunatics believe
it does this guy realize how out of
touch he is with the vast majority of
people who have ever lived sex has a
point and ought to be ordered toward
that point which is procreation you
realize how
crazy you said no man that's most people
agree with that even if today we live in
a particularly bizarre liberal moment
statistically 100% of people for all of
human history have believed what I
believe roughly about sex only these
radical lunatics believe it he does it
because I'm going to get attention Matt
Walsh has the anti-trans nich covered
and he got really famous off that I want
to be famous too I'll be the dumbest one
I'm against all contraception I think
condoms are
gay and what you know what unfortunately
in this medeor ecosystem that works
that's why they do it look we're
covering it hey look at how dumb this
guy is and a lot of right- Wingers are
huh oh yeah yeah the stereos seexual
think I don't want that and yeah and gay
I don't like gay people and I condoms
bother me I think he's right and he's
going to convince like two to 3% of
people like I don't even I don't even
think that pretty good I think you're
being far too generous to Michael nolles
and thinking that that argument would
even convince 2 to 3% of Republican
voters to like turn on contraceptives
like condoms come on just put a pause
here this is crazy R who's that going to
convince this is the official doctrinal
teaching of the Catholic Church
forever there are a lot of Catholics out
there a lot of Catholics in America
there a lot more than 2 or 3% of the
country a lot of Catholics around the
world I'm like B basically just reading
out of the catechism okay if I wanted to
get attention I'd put on a soft shoe and
wear a a sequent Blazer I'm not doing
that I'm just reading basic elements of
traditional sexual ethics and look you
again you want to go up against 99% of
women who actually use it even if some
of them answer an app oh yeah maybe we
should ban it I mean I use it earlier in
my life and I'd like to be a hypocrite
now uh or whatever reason or I use it
but I'm evil because Michael NOS said
I'm evil because I use I pause here when
did I ever say anyone is evil for
committing a sin when did I say that
that's not true so get your facts
straight he's putting it in quotes even
I never said that I don't think I use
the word evil anywhere in my monologue
the other thing he's wrong about is he
says 99% of women use contraception
that's obviously not true half of women
have gone through menopause
already right at least you you think
those women are on birth control so it's
a relatively small number of women and
then some of them at some point have
used contraception and a lot of those
women have turned against I mean this is
a major movement right now forget about
even conservatives and religious people
just ordinary kind of crunchy liberal
women who say huh you know maybe there's
something wrong and something not so
wise about pumping my body full of
unnatural hormones simply so that I can
be used for the sexual pleasure of
random men who don't want to commit to
me yeah maybe that's not such a great
idea it's not just us conservatives who
are pointing that out guys right now go
to jus.com
nsyt everyone here at the office loves
the genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector you
might be asking what this product even
does well if you've got sunspots dark
spots discoloration or dry skin the
genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector will help
those blemishes disappear in front of
your very eyes Kimberly from youngst
Ohio says my appearance has improved so
much since using genucel I love all my
genus cell products and my skin looks
younger now it's your turn to feel like
Kimberly but hurry this sale is ending
very soon take advantage of genus cell's
most popular package which includes the
Beloved Dark Spot Corrector this package
also includes the genell classic under
eye treatment you will get all these
products for almost 70 70% off genus
cell is so confident in their products
that you can try them for yourself
completely risk-free if you don't see
immediate results you will get your
money back it's very simple go to
gale.com nsyt start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say goodbye to
dark and liver spots bags and puffiness
under the eyes Crow feed at Jus cell.com
letter Y lettert genius.com nsyt Michael
NOS said I'm evil because I use I have
anacron
anarchistic
sex okay sounds fun yeah by the way that
doesn't sound too bad I
mean I like sex with lots and lots of
rules and regulations and only for
procreation and but by by the way now
seriously about these actually rules are
sometimes important there we go put a
there it is see lady you're making fun
of
me you're making fun of me because
you're using talking points from 1990s I
Am Woman hear me roar feminism nonsense
but we ain't living in the 9s anymore
honey we're living in the me too era
we're living in the times up era we're
living in the era where we've seen the
consequences of the sexual Revolution
that the conservatives had been warning
about the whole time but the Liberals
are observing it now too and so even as
she's making fun of me for saying sex
should not be anarchistic but should
actually have some Rule and order to it
even as she's making fun of me then
after the laugh line she says well
actually though he's kind of he's right
obviously but uh but how what a what a
funy daddy yeah yeah like depending on
what games you're playing anyways oh
good shank admits it too good glad can
we end the video there then folks
because after this whole wind up of this
ad Homam these strawman arguments this
NOS is a this he's seeking
attention this is crazy this is fringe
this is Extreme they both admit they
both admit that I am completely right at
least on the point that sex should not
be totally anarchistic that actually
there are rules there is order so then
the logical next question is well what's
the whole thing ordered for and they
probably don't want to state that
explicitly but it is implied by the
point that they've already conceded
let's actually look at the current
polling let's do that okay yeah because
I've got more data for Progress put out
a poll uh in October of 2022 asking um
would you be more likely or less likely
to vote for a candidate for congress who
opposes protecting the right to
contraception under federal law so that
is a broader question um not only having
to do with uh you know condoms but but
also birth control let's look at
Republicans right 40% say they are less
likely to vote for someone who wants to
ban birth control only 25% say more
likely but now Anna you know we're K
around about 2 or 3% but there it is 25%
of Republicans say ban it for by the way
35% aren't sure aren't sure I know but
this is a very broad question pertaining
to exactly what it was there you're
right it's extremely broad so you'd
expect the numbers to be much smaller
that's saying Republicans need to go
campaigning on we're going to ban all
these things I'm just all I am
articulating is the perfectly normal and
obviously true moral point that sex is
ordered toward procreation
congratulations re it's
a squid and you can extrapolate from
that as all political societies do
but don't put the words in my mouth that
I'm saying that every member of Congress
needs to go campaign against condoms or
something like that that's that's your
own imagination if push came to shove we
think obviously they're not actually
going to try to even the Republican even
a majority of the Republican voters are
going to be like no don't Bay
contraception that's nuts right and
obviously everyone else thinks it's the
craziest thing in the world although as
you see in the poll 9% of Democrats are
like maybe like what like 9% say yes
much more likely put a pause I thought
he was going to be arguing against my
point in this video but they keep as
they they've got locked and loaded
they're points to knock down my point
but they say huh actually you know a lot
of Republicans actually do think that
contraception is maybe not the best
thing ever well but there're those crazy
Republicans because they're conservative
and that makes sense that conservatives
are conservative but the Democrats
though they're going to oh actually man
almost one in 10 Democrats agrees with
noes huh well okay that's great keep
going guys you're going to be you're
going to be making my argument for me
better than I did in the great majority
of the country's bubble we're like yeah
this is the year 2023 we believe in
Freedom and people can have sex for
whatever reason they want why are we
judging their sex life oh that one was
too much fun that one wasn't what can we
judge whether it wasn't fun enough h no
you have to only do it for the reasons
Michael NOS wants so the great majority
of the country thinks these guys are
lunatics
okay ironic but there is a religious
contingent in this country including
some Democrats who go no no the sex
should be done by my rules and my rules
say only for procreation PA it's not my
rules it's God's rules first of all and
I'm not saying that that's the only you
know point at all it's the ultimate
point it's what sex is ordered toward
but it's not my rules it's God's rules
and even if you don't believe in God for
some reason at the very least you would
have to admit that is our civilization's
rules for 2,000 years yeah it's uh kind
of what we do here my position is you
know I think probably our civilization
pretty much kind of had it right they
they were weren't completely off base
when they had a consistent sexual ethic
for Millennia maybe we shouldn't just
upend the whole thing overnight because
there might be some negative
consequences to that that some of us can
foresee and others of us cannot but
which are there nonetheless so by the
way if you're married and you only want
to have three kids I guess that means
okay enjoy the three times you have sex
in your life because you can't have sex
before you're only using it for
procreation you can't use contraception
so you you want three kids three times
you get that first of all Chen seems to
think that you know you knock a lady up
every single time you uh do the deed and
that is generally not the case but two
uh there are non artificial
contraceptive means of uh measuring
exactly when a lady is likely to be
fertile which I'm not necessarily
recommending I don't I think it's good
to be open to life but in a grave
circumstance if one wanted to do that
they are extremely effective and they're
they're mocked these these methods but
they're they're extremely scientifically
Advanced much more scientifically
Advanced and sophisticated than you know
pulling a rubber out of a box from the
gas
station all right no no not all right
anyway keep going again the great
majority of the country thinks
lunatics but there is a conservative
religious element that goes sounds right
to me they're not actually going to do
it they don't practice it they're giant
enormous overwhelming Hypocrites all of
them use contraception put a pause right
there because now he's making an
accusation about something that is just
manifestly not true at the at the
recording of this video I have one child
who is one year old I have one child
who's 2 and a half years old I promise
you I am not a hypocrite on this issue
what's what's so telling about that
commentary there is Chen I I think
sincerely doesn't believe it's possible
that people could just be open to life
that people could actually just want to
have children not want to divorce the
pleasure of sex from the point of sex
would not want to you know go buy a box
of rubbers from a from a convenience
store all of them use contraception and
none of them actually believe this but
they go yeah we should we should ban
other people from having fun sex sex for
just fun no okay all right if you're in
that group yeah you're likely a right
Wier and you're probably nuts and we're
going to fight you and we're going to
win so how about it no one's going to
try to ban condoms it's just not going
to happen like it's the most ridiculous
thing ever they've driven down support
for a gay marriage by seven points and
it keeps going down put a pause there
that's not true we've driven down
support for same-sex relations period by
seven percentage points in just a couple
of years I think it was according to Pew
and it's not we who drove it down also
it's reality it's the reality of the
culmination of the sexual Revolution
that has done that I suspect drag queen
Story Hour had a lot more to do with
that I suspect the the bizarre Pride
parades I suspect the indoctrination in
the Elementary School classrooms had a
lot more to do with the decline the
precipitous decline in support for the
weird sexual Revolution type stuff these
guys batter and batter and batter and
batter so yeah they're not going to win
on this issue but they're going to keep
going and they're going to try to
convince religious people your religion
should rule everyone okay I'm sorry I
don't agree put a pause there unlike uh
Mr chank yuger over here who believes
that his religion should rule everyone
his religion of liberalism and decadence
and Decay well that has been ruling
everyone for a number of decades now and
the consequences have been completely
disastrous measured in pretty much any
way uh support for our institutions uh
patriotism hope for the future
self-reported levels of happiness uh
marriage family formation birth rates
it's just every measure of a nation's
success other than material financial
success sometimes so maybe we ought to
try a different religious view since
Chens has not been very successful sorry
I don't agree and I'm going to fight you
2,000% and so okay and by the way
Michael no is a giant giant Li what you
never use contraception no I don't use
contraception I don't think I ever said
I've never done anything wrong in my
life I was an atheist for 10 years I was
still sort of right-wing but in that
libertarian kind of like not not cool
way um but I I did all sorts of terrible
things fortunately on a lot of them I've
I've ceased to do them or I've uh
greatly you know diminished the amount
that I do bad things and on certain
isues like the one that Jen and I here
are talking about I completely changed
my mind on it and then just got rid of
it which is great to do especially when
you're married that makes it a lot
easier to uh to do that even so even if
one were to sin let's say a married
person did use contraception for
whatever reason if you if you have a
standard and then you fall short of that
standard and and you regret that that's
not hypocrisy that's called sin which is
a fact of human life that's called being
human and we mean old religious people
are quite in favor of Grace and
forgiveness and you know forgiving other
people their debts as we wish our sins
to be forgiven by God so that's not
hypocrisy hypocrisy is when you pretend
to hold one View and then you behave in
a way that's contrary to that view but
no he's still even at the end there he
can't believe that anybody would not use
contraception no you freaking boo okay
you he was in a movie where he's having
gay sex and put a pause there that's not
true I was in this undergraduate thesis
movie at Yale but it wasn't gay my
character was bisexual I I see a lot of
girls I see a lot of guys too but anyway
you know look to ch's point in my acting
career brief though it was I've played
hundreds of roles I've played I don't
know like two or three kind of more
feminite type you know like wimpy type
of guys but I've played soldiers all
right I played the devil once although
he I guess South Park to picks him as
kind of gay who's my cream puff I am
that's right baby but you know you play
one bisexual character in one Yale
undergraduate thesis film that's all
you're ever known for as an actor at
least I will say at least people are
talking about my acting work most actors
never you know their work never really
sees the light of day so I'm glad that
Chen has enjoyed it this guy back when
he was trying to be an actor and trying
to be famous he was like yeah gay sex
and contraception and wild sex I'm I'm
here for yeah and now that he's a loser
total failure in life and he couldn't be
famous with that now he's like I think
condoms are bad I think sex is bad
because I'm not put a pause there I
guess I need to teach chank one more
thing which is when you go to see a
movie or a play or a TV show you'll see
people on screen and they'll say things
and they'll do things they'll move
around they kind of wear costumes but
those costumes are not necessarily those
people's real clothing and the things
they say are not necessarily the things
that those people actually believe and
like the names that they're referred to
sometimes in the play or the movie or
the TV show they're not often they're
not the names of the real people because
they're doing something called acting so
I mean I mean I mean I mean I mean I
mean I mean it's like no it's bad bad
only for procreation I'm going to rule
all of your lives with my BS totally
made up totally hypocritical
principles okay Michael I got it you got
slightly Famous by saying something
totally and utterly asine in this case I
want you to keep saying it cuz I want
Republicans to lose all elections by
being radical morons like you I do
applaud you for being as passionate in
protection of condoms like the only man
in the country who feels this
passionately about protecting condoms
well you know good on her man I really
get a kick out of her because after
Chen's kind of Dia tribe with which is
mostly just ad hom and and invective she
comes in and totally guts his argument
got some bad news for you you're
done son is over because she says wow
chank you really get passionate about
condoms that's know good for you that's
good to be passionate about something
that's so important if you're getting
really fired up in defense of little
pieces of plastic to have meaningless
sex so you don't have any children and
you remain sterile something's going
wrong in your life and certainly
something's going wrong in your mind and
you should
correct it I hope that I've been able to
correct some of that in this brief
instruction yeah didn't gay I had a like
people